i don't believe this man's ever been on
the program so i'm thrilled to to fill
in that gap right now here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line is one of
the best in the business for a red hot
49er team wide receiver debo samuel here
on the rich hyzer show how you doing
debo i'm good how you doing i'm doing
better for talking to you um how's life
it seems to be pretty good for you
yeah it's going pretty good uh we've got
two in a row uh as a team so we're just
building the engineer around the
facility and just trying to get back to
what we was in 2019. okay when you're
running the ball downhill debo do you
see uh people making business decisions
is it is it is it something you're
seeing as your run downhill
i mean honestly i really don't pay
attention i mean if they move out the
way they move out the way if they don't
you know they just gonna feel it but
but you could see it though right you
come come on now you could see the eyes
maybe getting wide and you could see
them maybe getting down a little lower
than you know they're trying to get some
leverage here most most people kind of
turn it down but some people out there
just make business decisions and just
kind of throw their bodies just hoping
i'll fall down too well i mean that's
not really that's not really happening
uh i'm not i'm not seeing that do you
like the contact do you enjoy it of
course of course of course
so growing up uh i played mostly like
running back until
i kind of got to college and then i
transitioned to a whiteout
okay was uh spurrier the guy who did
steve spurrier um recruit you to south
carolina
or junior dude steve springer
uh and shawn and sean elliot
who did
elliot coach elliot okay so um did so
see uh the old ball coach never made it
to the the samuel uh living room that
never happened
no sir he did not make it there okay
all right and what was it like to be
around him even just for the short
period of time i said you're right it
was pretty cool he was a he was a pretty
funny guy i've never seen a coach don't
like that they didn't walk around it
at practice he had a golf cart that he
just he drove around the practice field
from period to period and if you go out
there earlier you'll see him out there
with his shirt all kind of trying to do
ladder drills and stuff but he was a
pretty cool dude well you know he was a
terrific quarterback back in his day
devo of course the old ball coach so
he's out there in the golf cart did he
ever take that to the actual golf course
that cart or that was just for price i
have no idea i'm not i'm not really a
golfer okay you know
get out into it so what was your draft
experience like you were taken in the
second round did you think you were
first round material
t-bone uh i actually thought i was
first-round material but uh if you go
back and just look at all the injury
injury history uh that kind of like
faded away a little bit but
i mean it was just a blessing just to
get drafted and just get in the league
and just show everybody what i'm capable
of and and clearly you've got a a coach
that sees it in you what's your
relationship with kyle shanahan like you
make out like have a have a great
relationship from from when i stepped
here until now it just we just been
building ever since i was a rookie and i
mean every monday or tuesday i always
stop by his office just to have like
casual conversation and even him and
mike mcdaniel as west welker those are
three guys that i stopped by every
monday and tuesday on like our off day
just to chop it up with him just to see
you know i'm saying where we headed at
this week for his plays and going
everywhere west and see you know saying
what he sees on the defensive end that
that we need to attack as a receiver
group so have you already had that
conversation with him on this tuesday is
that right oh no i really just walked in
the building and i came in here so after
i leave here i'm gonna go in there and
chop it up okay so what what's on the
agenda what do you think's on the agenda
we have no idea i'm not gonna lie i i
don't think you have no idea what's on
that junior calallen's
offensive guru so you know you never
know what to expect so i mean just got
to go in there with a with an empty mind
and just whatever he puts in i mean he's
been doing a great job with calling
plays and getting guys in the right
position to make plays so i mean i'll
put all my trust in him so uh what what
do you like to do if you're given a
choice run it or catch it and run it
what's your favorite to do i'd rather
catch it and run it why is that
uh because if i catch it i i got way
more space you know i mean it's it's
really not a preference but i preferably
like to to catch it in rest okay and you
got a good story about shanahan showing
you a play and you're like oh okay
that's gonna work and then it does you
gotta you got one i do not remember any
of them none of them because normally
that's that we've seen that where he
just says this is going to work we're
going to get it didn't he do that with
keto once he says we're going to this
one's going to go to the house and then
it goes to the house you said you're not
cow oh did i say that spurrier
okay what about what what about kyle
what about shanahan
uh
cow cow i mean if you if you watch him
and like
he's all way down like if we don't
offense he always he all the way down on
the other side just watching and he you
can see him sometimes talking to the
referee yeah he's all right now uh watch
killer this guy's about to hold and uh
and nine times out of ten he holds and
then we get to flag but a lot of plays
that he calls i mean you never know
what's going to happen any play that
kyle's call can end up being a touchdown
well and from the outside looking in
debo samuel here on the rich eisen show
sometimes we could see that it might not
be all roses and
and rose petals to be a receiver in this
system um this year we saw brandon ayuk
uh take some time to finally get back in
the last couple weeks to what we saw in
his rookie season is there some sort of
um
i guess standard that sometimes
receivers are held to on this team that
sometimes is difficult to achieve and
did you go through that
i wouldn't say it's like
a big standard uh we know what we know
kyle you know the area of college he
played white out oh and you know what's
working close to receivers but no nobody
on this team gets
coached harder than the white house
because you know we're cop look out guys
so if you if you watch the games that we
play you never see receivers blocked the
way we block
um that's that's one of the main things
that that cal emphasizes and all the
other stuff it just come it just comes
so i mean we're we coach the hardest on
the team so it is a high standard to
being a whiteout um and it's a lot to
learn
so but as you learn it you see um
as these past three weeks man you see uh
brenda nyu being a different player um
he had a uh him and kyle and john had a
great conversation about you know saying
what we needed him to be enabled for us
to win and you can see for the past
three weeks that he's just been balling
yeah i know but it's difficult for fans
on the outside looking in to understand
what that means like you know what does
that mean
the the standard and he and at some
point he even said that he now knows the
way to practice is that what it is too
right um
if you if you if you don't know how to
practice it's gonna be hard for you to
to play in the league like if you can't
practice fans there's no way you're
gonna go out there on sunday
and play fast and be your best so i mean
you have to go out here every day day in
and day out and practice and practice
hard as you can just to get ready for
sunday because you never know what to
expect so what does that mean for you
i mean did you have trouble learning
that going from south carolina in the
first year with san francisco or uh
but not really i had a i had a great
receiver coach at south carolina named
brian mcclendon um he's one of the
coaches for oregon he coached at
whiteouts and he was very very hard on
uh
on the so i kind of got a glimpse of
what it what it takes to to practice
hard and what it takes would be the good
white out so i mean i kind of took a lot
of that from him and we still connect to
this day a few more minutes left here
with debo samuel of the san francisco
49ers who are now looking like the team
that we saw a couple years ago for the
first time in 2021 here on the rich
eisen show is that fair to say does it
look like to you
what it looks like to me and so many
others like the last couple weeks that's
that's the team that we saw a couple
years ago do you get that sense right
now i got i got that since when um after
the rams game i see you just see the
defensive defense flying around special
teams flying around just flying around
on all cylinders on all phases i mean
once we play
uh once we play ball all together i mean
we're unstoppable you can see uh jimmy
had two picks first game back from his
quad and you see both
and fred and all those guys forming to
the ball eric ormstead and all those
guys um and then you just see
i mean we ran the ball 44 45 times
against the rams i mean you can just
tell what kind of team we have it don't
matter if we throwing it or running it
um all 11 guys out there just flying
around yeah and it just seems that way
to me um so what's your challenge
against the vikings team that just
beat the packers this is a huge game
coming up on sunday debo what are you
what are you thinking about that one
right now i mean we just we just got to
control the things we can control and go
out there and play out ball on sunday
what's the things you can control
hitting people is what you're saying of
course okay we just
play our physical game physical game
who's more physical you were kiddle
oh that's tough uh yeah i probably i'll
probably give it a kill i'm not gonna
lie well i mean it seemed like i had to
force that one out of you i i give it i
give it a kill yeah he seems but
only because he he he has the blocks of
the ends and you can see him pancake and
everybody just standing there i i give
it to him yeah i think he had vaughn on
roller skates a couple
i think i saw that i think i actually
saw that so all right so then who enjoys
contact more your kittle who enjoys it
more i say it's about even my face i
mean he's smiling though when he's
pancaking people i'll be laughing tuba
inside you know
[Applause]
i mean you see this guy he did not want
to tackle you and i just be watching
everybody just going to try to tackle
kittles sometimes and right they be
turning it down too they just be making
businesses so so you have to say
so you see you just don't want what
ramsay to see you laughing is that what
you're saying i don't care who's jimmy
laughing
you're in the mode right now i love it
you're locked in man you were totally
locked in so a couple of personal
questions for you is it true that you're
called debo because your dad liked the
movie friday is that true
yeah um growing up my dad used to say i
used to bully and fight a lot when i was
a little kid so he gave me a nickname
and the funny story is uh my mom
actually
thought once i got to college nobody was
gonna call me that and then she started
she started to see that everybody was
still calling she was like do they not
know that that's not your real name
why are they calling you that
so what was who does your mom call you
by your first is it taishan right is
that the yeah
my mom called me tyson well taishan okay
so that's i'm sorry i didn't know that
right because i've only called you deebo
so so you know when you hear that name
you're in trouble is that nah she never
called me devo she always say tasha no
that's what i'm saying when you hear
tyshon you then you know you're in
trouble is what you're saying when you
hear that name not at all okay look at
this it's like there's like other people
just calling me devo she just don't call
me diva okay it's just like when i was a
kid anyone who caught my mom would call
me richard and i would hear that
sometimes i know oh i'm in trouble when
i heard the name richard as opposed to
anything else but and then last one for
you uh debo uh so i guess you're as your
family as you're
have you ever met cube have you ever met
him now i mean have you ever come out
before okay we got to get that happening
i mean
you know uh chris tucker have you ever
read him you ever meet him never met him
either unfortunately the actor who
played debo has passed away last year so
i mean his nickname his nickname was
tiny i mean so that's pretty amazing uh
because you are definitely not that
what's your favorite uh your your
favorite thanksgiving side dish
debo samuel
i stopped you right there
what do you got it's too many of them
okay
let's go
matthew judon just said mac and cheese
was what trash is that what he called it
basically called a trap yeah what do you
think about i never had good macaroni
and cheese that's what i'm saying
oh
that's that's kind of hard
yeah um
i would say stuffing and gravy okay
all right um what is then the most
overrated
side dish then
what do you think ebo samuel most
overrated
thanksgiving scientist cranberries
yeah i think we're with you here too i'm
not i'm not really a um
i'm not a pumpkin pie guy deebo i don't
like it at all does that mean
does that make me a problem or what
yeah that's kind of a problem no
[Laughter]
kind of a problem yeah uh the i think
the exact quote is um it's just cheese
this is matthew judon on mac and cheese
quote it's just cheese and noodles and
it's not that good get it off the table
the bathrooms be less busy and everybody
will have a better day and quote on mac
and cheese matthew judon he never had
good mac and cheese
okay
okay i think that's uh we're in
agreement right there debo samuel this
has been a pleasure sir have a great
thanksgiving send my best to your coach
when when you when you walk into his uh
office like you say you do on every
tuesday say rich eisen says hello
um and and and then do me a favor
monitor if he makes a face
okay because i need to know all right
because i know that that's my business
decision i need to avoid contact if
that's the case you know what i'm saying
that's my business decision that's what
i'm saying yes sir all right debo samuel
have a great thanksgiving you keep
balling out you too okay that's debo
samuel everybody right here on the rich
island show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here